one thing you may not know about me is
that i am obsessed
with cookbooks i read two or three a
week and i have an entire collection at
home i'm talking floor-to-ceiling
shelves by the way
that's one corner there's like many more
walls of it
okay so i want to create a place where
we can all
share our love of cookbooks together so
this is cookbook club
[Music]
oh i kind of couldn't have
wished for a more incredible person to
kick
this signature segment off with he is a
legend in the food world and has the
biggest
heart ever his organization world
central kitchen has served more than
40 million fresh meals to people
around the world impacted by natural
disasters and
other crises please welcome the
incredible jose andres
hello drew how are you oh my god i am
such an
uber fan so this is our first cookbook
club
and this came out last year i already
have this in my collection
and um can you talk about the cookbook
that you're going to suggest for
cookbook club so that you're going to
turn us all on
too thank you for showing that but one
of my
favorite cookbooks i i love history and
i
have a big collection of all books but
for me was very important as an
immigrant to learn more about
the history of america through its
cooking
and this is my favorite the foot
of a younger land of
mark kurlansky if you
want and know what america was eating
at the beginning of the 1900s here
is a compilation of stories
essays that he found uh
in the library of the congress because
after the wpa the world progress
administration
i'm i'm too young to be alive when that
happens
they created a group called america eats
where they were paying writers to
document what traditions were
all across the 50 states so here you're
gonna be finding
amazing stories of america
that america doesn't know about so it's
an origin book
a historical book and a book with
recipes i think this is an incredible
way
a profound way if you will to kick off
cookbook club
okay you are such an important person
on this planet with what you're doing
with your life
uh well let me tell you drew thank you
but i i'm not hero
i'm just one cook that i'm very lucky
to be surrounded by amazing people
many of them cooks and chefs and
volunteers
that through through the wall when there
is a
fire we show up we believe that
sometimes
a plate of food can be the beginning of
a better tomorrow so
you will see us after hurricanes
earthquakes explosions
and quite frankly i have a team that
they don't deserve
and i'm so honored to be next to them
trying to
provide food to people in need well
listen
really you are a game changer for our
planet
the way you show up for people the
effectiveness
the galvanizing and organizing
the doing that you do it
is a true game changer sometimes
when you need people to take care of
injured
after a hurricane you send doctors and
nurses when you need to
rescue people you send first responders
and firefighters
when you need to feed people who you
should send well this is simple
it's cooks like me all around america
all around the world that we put
our know-how to feed not only the few
in our restaurants but to try to fit the
many after disasters
simple well you are a total inspiration
to
me and everyone else
you